welcome everybody to the no chance
qualifier here at second world tour
finals
my name is Mark we've swapped in a few
more members of our talent team we have
Michael Murray and we have spaghetti rip
as well what's good what's good what's
good tasty steve is the enforcer he's
going to be protecting me from these
guys just in case they try to grab my
arm but guys we are here right in the
middle of all the action there is a ton
of tech and still left here at the LCQ
and we've already seen some bodies look
telling people I love the John is
personally one of my favorite players of
the year and they really help why are
you saying that he sold these still new
to this I'm like bro the kind of players
that speak to their own characters look
I love that on top of it at such a high
level we've seen running black we've
seen news also still coming up we've
seen Cotto core we've seen so many good
players and if that's what it does or
you know to see ticking at this level
same people saying that did this else
did you is it for some people walk
cycling for this then the actual finals
myself included yeah
so what does it feel like what does it
feel like to you man like I've been
waiting to ask you this question look it
what has become of like Tekken even so
long into the lifespan like it's one of
the oldest games on any tournament
circuit but it's steel consistently
delivers when it comes to excitement and
hype right I mean it's a third here the
tour we're still seeing increasing and
all the numbers which is insane for any
game from what I've heard
and especially for me I have more time
to chill with you guys but now since
being producer I don't get to come out
to the men's as much but it's just been
a whirlwind and then here we are this is
the end of this tour I will seek you
with all the killers all these people
from Pakistan from Korea Japan all
Europe and especially players from Italy
we're about to see these guys go at it
because they're both from Italy Paisano
drama coming up Simo and it goes up
mistress torment tissue mon these two
are obviously to the top layers in italy
winter storm if you're not familiar with
him was so close to qualifying for the
first season of the world tour and last
LCQ in amsterdam he almost beat double
it was a joke you know so this guy is
really really good unfortunately has a
pagan show the himbo winners finals oh
my gosh he's fallen into the trap this
is athena and sabina bro oh big counter
hit there to start it off and here comes
oh wow
oh he is playing nervous i don't know he
dropped the combo now going the other
way mistress storm pushing towards the
wall here you know zaffinos one of the
characters we've been seeing a lot more
from different players players have
started to make their transition and
starting to utilize her in tournament
play yeah it's more it's mainly about
her movement that's what has been the
conversation about it yeah how good her
back - a side walks she can side
workings are other cats as cattle side
yes natural evasion as well with her
stances - definitely one of the scary
kickers if you have the knowledge base
with her to kind of just interrupt the
flow of normal Tekken for a lot of these
players
really waiting shadow he's like I can't
wait for this character to come back and
look at what he's done so far
oh yeah consistently and properly say
I'm just gonna play Safina GCC what can
subpoena is Rock Athena he's rockin
subpoena cardio but he mostly plays that
but he said it even before he's he said
before they even announced the
characters like I want subpoena back he
said that to me personally yeah we'll
see one of the guys on Twitter I hope
not nobody block he doesn't seem like
the very loud and loud and obnoxious
type anyway look at that Wow mr. storm
already up two rounds here against you
know we got to talk about tissue money
you know tissue Mon has been a
multi-year qualifier here yeah that
would actually qualify out of Europe
into the Tekkit of World Tour Finals Amy
of course not this time not this time
I've been a very hectic here for just
taking a say the competition
[Music]
we qualified here he is fighting out in
the trenches where is life people all
around the world been getting better and
better
get me on Europe the competition in
Europe it's so high it's to be the white
issue one hasn't been able to qualify
this year because he always manages to
use to someone yeah no we were talking
about the consistency or lack of
consistency from a lot of the players
that we've seen prior I mean there's if
you look at it you know number two and
number three on points last year we have
John ding we have who Don's dating even
qualified it's crazy and you know
players like John dick he went to every
single event almost every single that
qualified ladders are here in the LCQ
yeah talking about the question
capabilities it went bright under that
Ray Drive man you just don't want to
receive any emails while you're doing
commentary we understand we can still
send those to Virata by the way it's a
team effort so tell me I don't know I'm
not know to make me trustees yes I'm
hideous before MIT restore mused Nina
Hugh how the beauty like strong strong
Mina plan email show you right yes yes I
would pick the wife who's in the parish
regional final 2017 it was him and black
pit and winners finals if he had beat
black pit he would have been qualified
for that so like he's been very close
many times yeah it's off to a good start
so far all right yes man and tissue ones
been looking really strong I was
watching him off stream versus shrimpy
from Saudi Arabia and other people I
mean playing a good level but you see
Metro storm doesn't matter like he's a
strong player tissue man he's a legend I
mean he's one of the oldest players here
but not only that he's one of the
players that has been playing at the
highest level doesn't matter where he is
in the world obviously now residing in
Europe playing out of Italy but he's one
of the original main sheet crew from
Osaka it's a shame that he hasn't been
able to make his motor club we know how
strong mark is now especially with a
deal shaking on the dais bar he hasn't
really been able to make that transition
because he was known for modoch right oh
yeah yeah
and he counts as Europe now he's been a
long time we've got that permanent
residency this time getting it new
addition of course and it's so awkward
it's all that back that progress did you
always want to challenge the bathroom
usually you do like a tough job but you
know you people are somewhat used to
that and have enough power to do is a
different season one you to go into
manual back to yeah just mess with your
mind
he'll run up and do a blog what's up
he'll run up back to put his hands in
his pocket right don't want to deal with
that guy it's too scary
Hey look at that he is turning things
around now getting up two rounds here
against mr. storm uh-huh trying to turn
the favor I don't know man he's gonna
have to tie it up here obviously still
looking good ways to go looking very
very good every goal opportunity now and
take it to the port up a chance here
this is sticky situation here you gotta
be very very careful how you're gonna
deal with the mix-ups yeah that's the
thing about subpoena man so many
responses three stars is to deal with if
you don't know what to do then you gonna
get putty yeah and a lot of it comes
down to knowledge is one thing is a lot
of her tactics are either high or the
you know they have their very negative
but you got to know what the holes are I
mean she has so many different options
we need to know when to pick your shots
for sure have you got me trust on
getting on the board here in the second
game
Safina
a very popular cart in Pakistan as well
there has always been a very public I
didn't know cuz I was kind of [ __ ] on
the cart I like this bag but you need to
stop no but you and I I think of you and
I were on their Twitter train was
talking about how she was good - before
yeah I think we kind of underestimated
early on like everyone's now realizing
how good her moving - and go set point
now for Mitchell's book Tish you want
into the loser park and the LCQ he's one
of the first yeah he came back even more
when they release a business and that
man is a full-blown family man yeah yeah
here's the follow up here we'll continue
with the pressure right now big lead
here for mr. storm looking to send
tissue month of the loser's bracket
right sidewalk counter hit one more hit
raise your Ivy's gonna pull it out there
it is mushrooms wolf cross streams picks
up heart attack now what what's you go
for goes for the mid why is this man
tissue one always does is that why you
never know was that man your back 10
again we talked about yeah exactly right
just so disrespectful I think I don't
know if you guys watched it - shamone
básico coma at the USA - this guy's
really clutch we saw it there the clutch
factor he ended up taking it but that
was lost oh he lost yeah we came up to
one slope you were surround man close
games so much to play for so if you guys
are tuning in right now it doesn't
matter where you're tuning whether it's
the official channel or one of the
regimes from different communities
around the world thank you this is part
of our culmination of the exact second
world tour here for 2019 man it's been
many months since we've gotten here but
it's been fun it has been a fun ride
it's been a diverse year as well so many
new countries coming into the mix it's
been amazing
on Pakistan though at the moment I think
right now there are quite a number of
Pakistani players in the LCQ and all of
them seem to be progressed kind of what
we expect a lot of people are talking
about a thief but and also the John and
he had obviously very very strong
players to watch out there I'm excited
to see John and also I think we saw him
play early he had a tight match with Don
Yamato earlier probably the best of the
game with Eddie and it covers so much
ground we saw how he just made that's
been a really wish yeah but the big
difference here is you could also cite
seventh side one that's a big difference
here you have to utilize moving if you
pay the stars on yeah and I think that's
why I like players like Chanel seem to
gravitate towards her I mean you know
Chanel he's a moving monster to use the
Lisa for years so he's super happy that
she's included I think she she's the one
that are Chanel's the one that ran up to
the state didn't hook Mike Murray glad I
was working out of him like he's a big
dude I mean oh [ __ ] I was in the gym we
went to the gym like oh okay he's gonna
spot you right man I have another
feeling here's you know tissue money
obviously starting it's already kind of
slow here at match number three but you
know you can't count him out gets the
float there but in the aerial state from
the stands not able to get a full
submersion on the combo flash kick look
now he's in the lead just like that oh
here we go that's it that's it yes still
alive come on with a back turf Marrakesh
once again last chance here the last
chance yeah I don't know if that's
exactly how he wants to get his hits in
any man he's obviously taking big risk
trying to go for these kinds of things
yeah oh yeah yeah bTOB's in there punish
you to be the pro is he gonna throw it
away once again
turn up by tomorrow right now okay oh
this is a big factory oh my gosh this is
gonna come down to you oh my gosh
slipper tell us what you think in the
comment was delayed version of the
streak are you serious
I'm fine around here momentum on his
side one more you could do it he likes
to play on their disguise disappears
like that's what tissue monsters did and
I'm out of here
that's crazy madness what a strong
showing here she was definitely in
trouble that was not a you there was no
way he's playing comfortably like calm
in that situation but he obviously
worked if he took the match he had to
dig deep for that one and you know how a
lot of people say like you know when
they have really tense matches that took
years off of my life that took off every
last year that he had we're not gonna
see him next
but once again Victor storm just like
showing how strong he is but it just
can't go over the edge in the same thing
weekend's double washing who's so close
to winning again that's the difference
the experiences the years experience
that this one has I think it really
shows yeah wow this is gonna be a good
much as well we have s/m Ali from
Pakistan
are you familiar with I'm not familiar
yes he's a laborer he's one of the best
ladies in in Pakistan and he's been
doing a lot of stuff a lot of content on
YouTube as well we see so people were
very excited to see him play as well
okay it's because of us on a lien like a
log pocket those guys make me believe in
lace so much ya been watching those guys
matches quite a bit and you know a lot
of eyes have been focused on the
Pakistani I mean there's maniacs gaming
those guys
I've been streaming a lot more often
I've been watching so much of their
mouths yeah I have so many great
character specialists there and they all
have pocket geese and pocket Akuma a lot
of my information of Pakistan came from
awesome who used to be the best they're
back in Tekken 6 and you said to me look
it doesn't matter about Kentucky's this
they will find whatever character has
abusable stuff and they will just go
with it they'll run with me even if it's
not to do that that is a classic arcade
culture if you think about it they go
play with the strongest thing right
Chuck we used to be right yeah and they
said that the best character back in I
don't know if you grew this much but the
best character in Tekken 6 they say was
Jack Jack six was better than Bob better
than lost weight better than Bob yeah
yeah the right way if you use them the
right way though we didn't see me Jack's
in second six you know older woman with
money
Wow we had those events back they where
Anakin is smiling everybody with Jack
but I don't know man that was a while
ago that was 10 years ago
yeah yeah you go with the king
nice lock the man he executed three we
furnish on the first on the first time
I think geese is so much more fun to
watch now is using me because you'd have
to actually manage your meter oh yeah
and I think you know what do you watch
backhoes he's the perfect person to
watch when it comes
oh yes so well uses at the right time I
think it's really I think you're right
you can see a lot more back yes like the
back three to right I mean that the
giant wanted those people Wausau he was
watching it maybe just like all cool
thanks I know I think that's a good
requirement for like you know both of
the cursor do you think about these you
think about in someone because they
built the meters much slower than they
used to before people have to make sure
that it counts you don't want to miss a
combo visit makes it better players
because people just use you throw it
back through to like whatever they want
- yeah I'll get it back wait a minute
the RT so Oh Big Damn good night around
straight that's tough too cuz you know
you think about it in the matchup here
any risk here that geese takes is gonna
get punished pretty hard thing has a lot
of things that go are going for him
especially if he's able to duck at the
right time punch barriers all right
kings all only right but I'll have some
some doubles so you can at least like
papyri at the QCD to because that's a
very popular move from geese because you
see people fighting always free right
but it's starting to more and more that
people fight the character you see them
start to take advantage of it which is
like I said I said that in when I was
talking to ripping them it's a very
organic cake
the character and on how to defeat him
as well yeah learning how to fight him
as well just like Steve said anyways
we're gonna go to the Twilight convoy
switching Akuma huh Akuma that's a all
the meters
King fight Tsukuba very well oh yeah so
I don't know this might be even tougher
who knows
we'll see this was like one of the
matchups with that pre-release that
bronzer kind of figured out right like
yep I don't wanna give our sponsor but
like you know the damage is not as high
but you still get the combo you stop the
momentum yeah boy bill gets the scoop
there with the giant swing throw let's
see what he has nice while standing
forth oh this guy knows a lot of
equipment in Pakistan here we go yeah
can you can you imagine doing this link
do you think he knows how to fight
against Akuma it's like giving it to see
what he does here alright now starting
to change it up here oh my gosh counter
hit and he gets the ball here what's
gonna do noticable right like previously
you would have gone meat devil would
have would have on big fight Riley right
now on set point Allah seems even able
to take it here over me oh yeah
comfortable which one for dinner you all
weeks now Oh nah it didn't the
figure-four on top of it oh nice
something here we go should go to the
ward as well all that new stuff
all right misses the second hit doesn't
matter he just keeps the pressure there
oh no could it Lord stop it's okay one
more hit should do it here for Essen
it's got a little bit of meter here
though oh he's chillin bro he's chillin
okay Jack watch that that's going to
protect boy okay counter Hey
I don't think he's gonna mind that
though that's a pretty awesome looking
very strong it takes over me to shoot oh
it was over at the point where he
reversed the Warthog right kick I was
like Joe this guy has a good read
raggedly screw takedown okay but yeah
regardless uh I like that I like saying
my boy can get a little you know a
little shot stuff I didn't know about so
it's even better
but these matches are getting even
better time we got coming up I wish I
didn't look at the preview monitor but
you do have some crazy matches here we
go there's one of them right now so we
have you you also using Safina whether
it was one of her favorite characters in
tag to going up against a Gucci so I
could I know right now watch are you -
and she's definitely been playing a lot
looser character her and Kenya were just
bugging me so long all right nice gets
the walls done here the splat and the
fall for the dump or bushing I want you
know I just got a comment as a fan like
I've been so into the different
characters being used in the season I
mean obviously a lot of people have
their things to say about season three
but I really love juicing the character
variety yeah the characters are all I
know stuff Michael you can probably
speak to this but balancing in for
competition but also balancing for what
is such an important thing that's it
juice and she's a lot more fun more
recently - I've been picking up her on
stream I play the more damage from the
yeah I saw you I saw you tweeting about
it actually I'm talking about
I used her you know that one here master
Cup I didn't do so well the damage
output just wasn't like but now she's a
bit better she carries a bit farther -
yeah and on top of it just you know
season three in general like the damage
damage you carry everybody right
everybody definitely put in the time as
long as the lab she came up with a lot
of tech I feel like she felt that she
because she's she's missed is it's done
already
yeah Yahoo she from Malaysia is still
gonna be there in the loser's bracket
we'll see if we'll be able to see them a
little bit later on but we're gonna get
our next match small the biggest
definitely blow me up all day but yeah
that's definitely not blowing me up all
day no time no katana Julia still yeah
alright she was easy to molly until
Julia came out yeah cuz she was forever
like a Julia player started I believe in
in attack - well she you Stacy right
back yeah yeah
she's always askin
I've seen it before so where is she
promised she'd spent stunt okay so you
know she hangs out with G in those days
you know there's different yeah she's
part of that one
okay she's cool she's a staple of a
vaster cup she's been there
and she's really pretty strong I got
crap a K are you all right Steve you've
been mixing up coaching buses Tata for
now
yeah this is gonna be good a K is
another one of those players super super
strong represent the Philippines I was
actually talking about him and dojin
with a Obama earlier yes just saying
that like even though they're kind of
the forefront player that I look at from
the Philippines the Philippines overall
in 11 players Phillip Aaron's away yes
and there's you representing I'm a fan
of it came almost I'm a big fan of a can
told you for that matter I just really
love the fact that they're super young
and they've always been traveling to try
to get date they're always trying to
maximize this but just a really start
difference between dojin and dojin is
the guy who's looking in the frame data
you know that's his whole thing but okay
he doesn't he's not like really up on
all the fees I feel pleased by feeling
oh yeah I think we kind of got that
feeling when we first saw him at the tag
to world finals where he ended up
demolishing a lot of the Korean Japanese
players I think that's what makes him
dangerous a lot of times too scary
unpredictable man I remember that that
looks like to Monaco him versus helping
read your double flip down over everyone
hit man it's crazy
here we go starting it off with a K in
overtime and Shaheena card says well the
topic of conversation a lot of people
when even was first introduced they
didn't play but I feel like he's always
had like the great basic like taking
tools he got it down for anyone he's got
the good and now he's got like that down
that down for a 4-2 extension out all
the details pane like
I think in general just as damage buff
mine if you think about it his torches
you get like 72 that make up a downfall
to know which is crazy I thought which
is really funny it is a thing one of the
things has happened like to like just
competitive fighting games in general
right being in front of a crowd
sometimes people who legit sway you from
cheers alone don't listen to the crowd
surf on you know internationally a key
has been to quite a few events not able
to really capitalize it the last time we
really saw at least on CW masterven see
got poppy at the green event but from
there we didn't really see him not too
much he's been obviously doing very well
at the local level in the dojo events
yeah but he started it off to you're
super strong with Evo depend where he
ended up getting second place yeah so
you know the potential is that this
whole tournament is that oh yeah would
not be surprised therefore that's the
thing to you know a he's actually been
grinding out Julie a lot lately I've I
watched a lot of their local events they
stream a lot a lot of it and a cheap
half Tekken at the level with their
televised over there as well they do a
lot of great things I think to kind of
enrich the the game there it's on one of
the popular actual sports channels over
there as well
all right the follow-up here keeping him
at the wall here gets the punish a key
looking to close it out look at I'm
trying to get those shotgun mix-ups
intake they're having none of it
you can see dojin in the background
actually aka dojin have been teaming up
recently for their their team
tournaments that they've been happening
in the Philippines seeing great success
together they actually won the team
tournament and the ref major earlier
this year too I think is a good
combination to have as well by the way
you science and feel yeah yeah that's
like the ultimate combination man can't
really tell from here but he's just so
passionate like that time of F major he
was crying man he was like in tears
after he lost like and that's the thing
man I love that kind of passion
especially coming from like like you
said man the community is so strong so
you know they're putting in the work to
make it count
yeah and if the Filipino fans are
watching right now I got to give a
special shout to them one of the most
passionate and amazing crowds out there
just for Tekken if anyone has a chance
to go to Reb major major make sure you
do so after all these years of the
ticket project I finally went out this
yeah you said they're so awesome I was
talking about that on stage two it was
incredible finally just feeling like I
was telling mark man there was a Comic
Con at the same time
Murata and I just wandered through they
didn't even notice that some of them and
they were dressed up as technique
characters like everywhere really
strolling by and they don't even like
notice
crazy oh my god the wall Carrie here
into the damaged man that's definitely
the biggest thing positioning the season
is just about me to get some every
comeback oh it might but what a comeback
therefore moving on to a game was
putting in work there got the nice wall
here you got the combo but it wasn't
enough here gets a punch parry in the
next good okie as well we don't seem all
the time in the world for that much okay
pushes up the wall here nice
confirmation very good one too many
times
oh my gosh you have to be careful here
don't guess wrong what's the mix-up
let's write a little scooter right there
that was a nice little stutter right
there all the time
all right two rounds on this back again
yeah putting the pressure here on a cake
he's gonna have to make some adjustments
okay should take a Google i/o any drops
up for three doesn't get it he wanted
the spiky one of the follow-up okay
you had to punish in the wasa default so
everything commit today and that's the
thing so bogus on when inner rage has
really started putting even a big slips
on a K is this gonna continue though
that's a question right here
hope that's a big risk i gotta respect
it though we gotta respect his she's
starting to go in with a lot more fifty
fifty full cash now because julie has a
very strong full cash mix-up oh yeah and
she hasn't find success with it but
again it isn't it 250 right there that's
actually got that first round she's up
two rounds yeah this thing's so scary by
the wall you know the meet with the wall
sending three tracks and does wall splat
it close enough and it's safe and it's
saying that's the key right oh here we
go again bow and arrow oh boy oh that
was so sick and look at the damage here
it's gonna do it the wall ouch haha
extra rays damage as well not over yet
and they got him back in the game no
luck use it the Rays drive the mid
option oh you already scouted it out wow
maybe should be able to tie it up here
we're going to a final round here match
number two coming down to 50
and that's the thing he wants it's about
knowing the race - you know where she's
able to maximize using the bow and arrow
the while saving free oh wait yeah I
mean could would for a hot kick though
that's the thing is like it's great to
get damaged but it's great to get damage
and positioning like crunching the
ankles oh that might be all she wrote
you're right hey write his his like
hotcakes are you saying ma'am over thumb
is definitely warming up right there
though no yeah again if you just just
guess correctly in some of those 1550s
would have been it yeah sometimes just
comes down to that especially in a
person - man yeah I mean they are 50/50
right the good side or the bad side it's
really good pretty good showing oh yeah
this is winter side still so she is
still in the tournament we might be
seeing her a little bit later but we do
have more matches coming up and this one
right here the local hero local hero
book going up against Larian from Canada
male we have so many countries
representing here at the LCQ the amount
of different flags I've seen so far all
right oh yeah yeah we were doing a
session
Wow was it the main man not again it was
like sweet like brother yeah there's a
lot of European semi it was surprising
to you like this Dolman here fits a
computing ball to just hit the waterfall
I mean and that's always been the case
like even last year when you're in
Amsterdam oh I gotta say it though so
much empty with so many people in
Amsterdam that's Mexico for a lot of
depends on one other I'm sure no one
wanted to miss out on it again oh yeah
that's the whole point like and look
I've been through a lot of like events I
can tell you right now when it comes to
the Tekken World Tour de planners have
or every time I go every time Italy yeah
and I know as well from from the
European side of things is that that
finals so many people came for the first
time to that event and it's actually
trickled down to the actual tournament
we have now there's over all our numbers
are getting a lot bigger because of that
event oh yeah we did some number
crunching we saw some studies i mean ii
has just grown around the world and
that's great you know obviously grew a
lot in Europe last year I was about
payment in Americas and even in Asia
especially parts like you know the
Philippines Thailand here oh my gosh
took a walk Harry well to pause me as
well as nice no punish step with the
right punish again going towards the
other side here let's call Aaron it's
gonna cause an upset early on imagine
book getting introduced about 100 my
gosh oh great final round here match
number one this is the final match oh
wait
oh so you're a wee it's 1:1 already it's
cuz we just tune it in the middle as a
match I wasn't ready for this and now I
am afraid because I'm hoping put wins
there should be a massive upset here the
local hero the car this this could be
big because he has all this meter as
well if he's able to push ports other
side of the wall he might be able to
expend some of that meter that lies at
the wall is so scary down for oh my gosh
countering didn't seven enough season
three
rage
Steffie at the right step he wasn't deep
enough okay the local hero that was
getting dicey book very good stuff
oh shut off the book he gave us the tip
on the boxing match so that was really
really cool you guys were all there but
on different sides of the same walk in
and I was like Marie he turned back and
I was like what and it was really cool
I'm glad it was cool because I got a
picture with the champ like because you
told I told you right we need to go to
the same see I can tell you like what's
going on like this definitely I'm
definitely this is crazy so this is
probably the worst alliterate
alliteration match we're gonna have it's
gonna be an issue versus naxi na xie xie
so nash for the USA feng player versus
me sheep from japan who also uses fang
but a number of other characters we'll
see how this works out this is winners
quarterfinals of their pool later half
of the season a bit Cena staying on a
few of like some of them you know the
weekly tournaments the online
tournaments as well he's been you know
placing well mostly known for you know
being a sparring partner with a lot of
the great players in the East Coast
especially spirited those guys play
together I believe he uses like you said
maybe picking some other cards as well
but you did really world out that's one
I'm a came with mockery I think yeah
Lisa
Anna as well yeah and he also used his
Fang but which character he's gonna be
bringing to the the table I have no idea
hmm now she now she's really good I was
talking to him earlier no we talked
quite a lot and he's really really good
but in tournaments he's just chokes yeah
he was I never dropped normally never
sometimes those nerves get the best but
I've also seen nashi make some crazy
comebacks it's like once he collects
himself and gets back in the game he's a
beast
he's a beat he's been able to beat some
of the top American players
but Nashua knows guys and he's been
playing Tekken 7 and like traveling for
the tool even before it was called the
Tekken world tour yeah he was there he
was there
he's one of the I love one of the things
I don't we talk about this a lot like
when we see people at tournaments going
back but when I see people still playing
in tournaments um when they came from
Wizard World I'm like that's old deep
because that's devil not to a bunch of
how long wait I love the wizard world of
it's because they've traveled all around
that was the closest we got to having a
local presence for Tekken 7 like a lot
of reports where that was wonderful yeah
that rentals a beautiful thing and look
at what it's done look at what it does
for competition to have access to it and
letting these guys play magic so winner
winner gets to keep both both of the
vowels definitely about the body is that
true mirror match
here we go man I love to see this though
you get all these international players
you fly for avenge right before that
they're all in Thailand like playing it
I think that's the beauty of the LCQ is
we're gonna see more matches that we've
never thought we were gonna see compared
to what we're gonna see tomorrow where
it's a lot of the same players that
we've seen throughout the entire year
yeah yeah this is where we're gonna see
a lot more surprises I'm pretty excited
all big-block in a big fun day that's a
surprise we're trying to go for the
snakehead cheek yeah he went for the
good old American style unable to land
it you trying to test the baby
sometimes you gotta test these players
right jump it this one has a back one
palm County here Oh what it done he gets
a wall but adjustment here wall
okay sit early actually trouble back
really close to that wall okay wait a
minute he's running up on them he's
trying to get some pressure going yeah
but unfortunately back against the wall
that's it yeah new stream as well new
stuff so sick
yeah man you were looking here that's
how you turn if I started looking there
okay oh he got him in the back here you
got to be careful and he scouted it
right he's like you know I had to play
fingers look I'm a fine player myself
nice delay on the last hit the extra
damage good stuff initial three and I
guess he's got right obviously they play
the same character playing a lot more
cautious this happens to me if I play a
merry match I'll freak out even like
they know everything I'm going to know
all the tricks they know everything
oh he dropped the combo there didn't get
the fourth chord right kick this could
be problematic here yeah no need to look
any bigger it's not for mushy good show
poked away alright Andy still got the
comedy for
good backlash definitions of punish code
I think she might be in a tough
situation here I mean you got to think
about it it's about knowledge I mean do
these players know some options here if
she loses here for example and he
switches characters that could be a bad
trap that he's gonna put himself into it
yeah this is utilizing the bat camp
where he does well at the moment
oh rage I like how he backed up right
there get away from the low option out
of back turn actually still fighting it
out though oh he had it right there you
gonna let it rip at the launch quick
duck final round here match number one
that was that's something he has it been
making the commitment with a reverse cap
post oh yeah you got me doing it now to
Superman I'm trying my damnedest only
look right here nice you should be able
to close that out there it is headbutt
now in season three to be used opponent
closer to you I used to be that you can
only really use it at the wall for
pressure because it was very easy to
back that shout out the pressure but now
you know it's a lot better to use in the
open but yeah I mean the defense from
Michigan finish off nicely sparrow
training partner he's the best guy he
came up to me as well I felt it on D
it's so soothing you know yeah
is it so playing Eddie he's uh I'm gonna
tell you right now it's girls been doing
of these
Eddie versus the world yeah fine all the
punishing right and for every character
across the cast he makes a stream and he
doesn't entire set and he's like this is
what you need the punish with any person
whatever character goes down the movie
and he learns along the way obably saw
him get one second place always a damage
last master win Anika I think hasn't
figured out a answer for the bat camp oh
yeah because initially using it a lot at
there again you know he needs to try to
chase it down if you can and he's
playing it like range three on top of a
he's playing really far out yeah that's
the thing to it I think that's why he's
going forward with the head but so much
he doesn't want to take too much of a
risk that will put him outside max range
rebounds oh my god
initial set point hair wasn't that's the
thing to be using that reversed couple
steps kind of putting the fear in - yeah
second-guess his approach I mean Linda
she is so close now she's been doing
really good at that up close game and
that's why this she started losing back
hip bone to get out of there and look
what it did it turned that hold fair
first match alone and now he's all set
oh now for too much longer - you can get
something started a little chip damage
right there
Oh wrong punish go for the break he
still has the screw here rage Drive
available that's the right time to do it
don't you dare turn your back on be nice
he had the right people of course they
got the aggression knowing that you have
to chase him down the ass but now you
can use the stage to your advantage
right you feel closer close to the wall
lets it rip this time definitely gonna
get wall now oh yeah fortuny there look
at this he hasn't been raised but it's
very dangerous
yeah back to the oh my god this is bad
chuck's this bed now about even uses a
head puts nasty range Oh again the blue
stuff the boulders blue shoulders
oh boy like to change up this time
a little stronger when it comes to that
offense definitely I - you back in this
game
[Music]
you're like checking your pockets
drinking through the headphone able to
close it album in what a pretty tight
set between these two obviously yeah I
actually had a hard time just finding
his way in
once the reverse Kempo really started
showing its dominance here and making
him second-guess himself that really
changed everything
Oh huh oh yeah chunky another one of the
training partners of spirit in - mm-hmm
I mean he's been traveling a lot this
year yeah came down to Europe to Greece
for that to go pretty well yes still
sticking it with geese a local player on
the right I guess Olivia all of my
outfits are sick like all of it
if you're royalty you gotta be right
yeah I think I've seen Steve show those
boots and I want that cardigan I need
counter-hit there with a four for home
plus 2 has the wall let's see what he
does to convert here Rick so what you
guys
- you guys see me noctis's so far today
no actually this is the first Noctis
we've seen today right yeah so now we
know there's at least two noctus players
here in the LCQ I'll get to swipe at the
follow-up there that should close it out
look at that rung around number one but
the thing is you know oblivion was doing
such a great job really controlling the
pace of the match but it was just those
key moments where oh gosh oh he's well
versed right he's been around for quite
some time originally like a CD player so
he knows he's been around the block a
few times when it comes to these
high-pressure situations as well it's
just like dealing with a certain
character split knock is a whole new
ball game I feel like a season 3 top a
at the last LCQ now I saw the way he got
top 8 was the most clutch high so this
guy's very very good oh yeah didn't use
the beater but hey live to fight another
day he yeah and he also just found out
that his opponent ate the mix-up from
quarter circle back - yeah so he might
be able to use that a little bit more as
well but it has been hurried not just
can't parry yeah and he's already done
it once yeah yeah ooh point-blank all
right you should be able to close it out
here do a ton of damage this is gonna do
a ton of damage
- Bryce you two went for the for one
[Music]
that's why you gotta finish your combos
kids finish your combos don't leave that
console until you finish your combos I'm
not gonna let you leave my mom I said do
it but yeah finish your combos do your
frame data study but yeah that was a
really clutch that's right that truck he
closing it out yeah yeah he's definitely
you said he's clutch he's definitely one
of those guys on top of that he's very
execution heavy so he's probably gonna
optimize in a lot of situations
sometimes the nerves hit some but more
times than not he's the guy was gonna
maximum also remember those crazy combos
you didn't talk to him that's him
my personality my boy knock oh you went
for the neutral jump to start off you
really wanted to get something going on
there
noctus and this isn't as well it kind of
feels like the scrubby stuff going left
and the you really solid stuck up up so
he's a better character this season
anyway yeah he has more of a second
parent appeal that which I really like
you have a sticker of step 3 almost of
the hat thing where it's like geese
actually doing size 50 if the way I
don't know you see that's the thing you
always trust Steve you never trust
ripped yeah
I only say that if rip was here I'd say
the opposite one round away from taking
a set fight he is working on a clean
sweep here playing online now let's go
God try something new - lucky for the
quite the carry here let's see what he
does with it oh baby those pedals
and we're going right back into it cuz
much y'all that you got who dance the
man that's right he's out here for
they'll see ya a lot people have
forgotten about the fact that he's here
the LCQ man is he qualified of course I
she's a champion the first year yeah ii
ii yeah me now he's like he's like sorry
I'm late but yeah I'll be there yeah
nice to see him of course the question
is did you bring the turtleneck right
I'm trying to see the turn simply not
anywhere near coal try to go with the
twin Lance at the wild sandy for ends up
closing it out John take that first
round here yeah definitely one of the
papers to win this with us Helsinki but
he has to play a four month yeah that
thing is Mishima's have to be on for
anything you have to believe in yourself
right you gotta believe in yourself how
much do you think that he changes to w
affected because obviously like he's
clearly done as well the up ford for now
don't give me that back for guarantee
that you have to kind of - off the
traffic stop I think that really hurt
him and his playstyle to him that's what
you he does this woman I think that hurt
I mean honestly cuz I mean afford for is
still say it crushes better it's it's a
lack of overall damage and maybe okie
does what he's missing right but the
thing is if you're not gonna be at event
line one of those guys like I'll play a
character and like look the higher the
execution the better it looks cool and
it feels better and everything stops
food that's a good example right there
right and what is my dude you know I
don't know if you guys are called chingu
but he's basically taught me Tekken when
I was tagged to ya I really started to
learn okay and they're like okay jig was
actually a legend yeah when you join and
you learn the game you have to start
with Paul already and I went with it got
my ass kicked for like a whole year
before I could actually start playing
but it was worth it you know I have a
lot of people like nerd Josh one of
those people is like yo Steve man I want
to get like to the meet and he's like I
want Asya I'm like you can't do that
like a nerd josh is God like I don't
like bro that's a hard jump to go from
like just go into taking a start with a
machine where you are you're actually
asking to lose like it's hard
you don't fight a while so satisfying
satisfy like yo I'm tryna hit this down
for it to electric I'm like bro I mean
there are a few things more satisfying
than landing like a counter hit or like
polygon face or maybe for health suits
in a row I mean what's what's better
than that is outplayed yeah it's a it's
like a multi thing right even no matter
what game you play there's not many
games that you played that you hear that
don't feel like oh man they do good
probably don't know that when we remade
the game doing the Left recipe like this
is sound like have to put so much care
in detail into making sure landing in
electrical feels good sense otherwise yo
man you guys change the Brian laughs no
it's just like actually it's the same
but it's soul bet is like it's we've
used it for so long that when you
upgrade all like the sounds and stuff
like that it affects the game so that's
the same thing that was a very strong
second match from codons and hopefully
we'll be able to see this legend later
on in the tournament I mean you got a
look at the results for the last three
years for Tekken World Tour first place
the first year second place last year
and this year who knows who knows maybe
he'll make it to the top 19 that is so
sick to like not really participate in
the tour but then come breeze through
LCQ how many people are forgetting like
we talked about all these players here
but I'm pretty sure this is the first
time we say a coup Don's name like but
like that's the thing and it's no
disrespect this y'all musta forgot it's
so many strong players man it's so many
strong players and you guys are gonna
see a lot of them after we come back
from this break more LCQ action right
after this